好 上两个信息市场就是大户目的反弹
我说一下几个事情
就是大家可能会比较关心的
就是一个就是所有人都在关注的就是特朗普的关税
那么昨天特朗普的关税政策和中国是达成协议了
其实你可以看他达成协议的三个国家
一个是英国其实 一个是中国
然后还有一个是台湾 那个三个地方被台湾地区吧
就是这三个被达成协议了 那是三个达成协议
我们观察下这三个东西其实对市场的影响还是非常正面
就因为从2月份下来很大程度上是大家一个反转
就本来觉得Trump的policy是probusiness
然后发现他糊搞 糊搞以后就pricing了他不care
就是我们叫left tail的risk
就是他政府层面 白宫层面不care这个市场会怎么样
那么其实上一周的上两周吧
上两三周的这个市场的一个反弹
他本质上是把这个left tail的risk给拿掉了
觉得其实白宫还是 somehow是在乎这个市场
然后Truepolicy并没有就是那个tariff的policy并没有那么的差
然后我们以前pricing的可能太多的东西
那其实对于tariff这件事情
我挺早以前4月份的时候我就提过
他有可能会短期里面达成协议
那么我其实没有想到中国和美国会谈得这么好
大家好像已经要喝白酒 要庆祝的样子
那现在这个时点我本质上还是保持一种谨慎的
谨慎的悲观 谨慎的乐观
就我不觉得这个市场现在是一个可以就是formal的一个市场
因为这种政治上的policy它其实变化会非常快
因为当然后面90天的谈判谈成什么样子
大家还不太知道吗
那么整个市场拖起来我觉得有几方面因素
就说几个比较重要的吧
第一个就是tariff大家知道
就是本来觉得我们刚讲政策上的政策的影响
其实对于所有政策的影响都是一种情绪性的表达
它没有是在固执层面或者是在公司盈利层面这个东西发生
它是一个情绪的表达
那么但是上两周其实是一个copra earnings
我等会会带我们就讲一下copra earnings的情况
我们上两周的时候其实讲过
好像那个时候那个股稿好像已经出来了
股稿软意已经出来
那么在今年演出的时候特朗普的政策
其实伴随着大家对于AI的一个质疑
因为正好在2月份的时候是DBC出来的时候
大家不但是对AI的质疑
其实本质上对于现在这些AI核心的这些公司
主要是在半导体和算法的公司和云的公司
这两个是比较这些比较重要的
那么他们到底有没有足够的算理需求
然后有没有足够的算理需求
去形成云厂上足够的盈利
然后让云厂上继续去做CAPEX
那这个问题其实我们前几周每一周都讲到过
我一直是核心的观点是觉得美国可能会率退
那我说一下我的我觉得任何一个
就是你在投资上面都要有一个最最Fundamental的
这个对于经济的一个看法
或者是你对于这个事情的最最Fundamental的一个判断
那么即使在中美贸易达成就是现在Truth
叫停火协议吧
在停火协议之后
我的Fundamental对于经济的一个看法没有改变
就是本质上我觉得美国还是有很大概率会率退的
我觉得可能一半一半吧
就是甚至可能会超过一半
有这样的概率会率退
当然了投行你可以看很多投行的report
那么他们都相对来说更加乐观一点
比方说高盛会觉得35%的概率
昨天晚上调到35%的概率和率退
那我是感觉率退的概率还挺大的
就是现在政策上
因为你永远是对于政策在做切线
那么现在政策上来看的就是那个tariff现在变少了
然后可能年底还会有些退税
那么这个对于很多投行开始变得更加乐观一点
比方说Morgan Stanley已经开始看那个破信高了
我看那个S&P破信高
那我暂时这里还看不到
因为我觉得我对于政治理解我会更加谨慎一点
因为去做research是一回事情
去本质上去做投资是一回事情
因为你做投资的话
它政策一变的话你会很惨
那地仓位我其实仓位比较低的时候
就上来就跌下来的时候仓位比较低
然后涨回去的时候现在没完全涨回去
那个涨的时候也没有变
其实我觉得今年其实在政治的这个因素影响下面
其实少抽作为好
这个个人感觉
因为很多机会其实你不是一个核心的圈子
你不太知道他这个就是政治上会怎么走
那我说一下我核心的市场的判断
核心的市场判断是经济继续会slow down
美国经济会会变化至少变化或者衰退
那有衰退的概率
第二个美联储不会行动
那或者是美联储会非常谨慎的行动
这个是我对联储的一个理解
包括我们上周有一个很大的观察点
就是美联储的这个态度
机器会的这个态度
其实我觉得这个更加让我强化
联储不太会大规模的采取行动的一个观点
那么我们现在在美联储角度处于一个Limbering state
什么意思呢
就是我在一个非常难的抉择或者在迷惘之中
这个词是相当于一个在记录教里面
在一个就是临界状态的这个迷惘状态的这么一个意思
就是说我们现在处于软的数据
已经开始感觉开始下降了
那上一周的数据还可以
但是我们总管前一段时间一些经济数据的话
我们会觉得美国经济的软数据其实已经开始在下降
那么但是同时的话
的硬数据还需要很长时间才下来
那么连处在看到硬数据下来之前
我的感觉它是不会动
所以经济可能会slowdown连处不会降息
那么这个过程当中
整体公司的盈利是要往下跑的
那S&P的盈利的话
你可以看一季度的话
这个数据是一季度
一季度的话其实还是比预期要好不少
那你这个增长12%
但是相对于2024年的话
你会看到这个增长已经在往下跑
那么接下去如果说是经济变化
连处不大行动的话
那么我是感觉S&P的整体的这个earning growth
它是一定会下来的
所以在这过程当中
我觉得AI和科技公司相对来说
还是比较defensive比较稳定的
特别是前一段时间很多
那现在稍微有一点反弹
但是前一段时间还是跌了挺多的AI的概念
包括半导体耗益
那么这些它的earning是比较defensive
我们会看得到上两周以来
所有的这个你可以看到Microsoft
其实市场反弹一个是Position 头寸
第二个是那个Terror的谈判
第三个是公司的盈利和回购
那你会看到Microsoft的backback
然后Amazon backback
Google Meta Apple
他们都在他们都开始回购
然后业绩还都不错
所以公司业绩和回购
加上市场的头寸相对来说比较轻
我看看我有没有这个团队
这个是我们看到美国的systematic position
就是所有的cta加上vlog control的这个策略
一般的时候大概去年的时候
250个别链2500亿
然后最低的时候到了35个别链
现在大概是90个别链
这个数据现在稍微上来一点
就是前两天
所以大概现在大概90个别链
那我们会看到就是说
市场的对冲叫做systematic position
就是我强制自动的交易的那些头寸
基本上抛空了
所以所以那个就是你会看到
一旦vlog下来
就是我们最近看到这两天
昨天看到比方说vigs下来
他们这些头寸就会慢慢回去了
因为它是强制性的头寸
一旦波动率下来
然后市场开始上涨
它去世跟踪也好vlog control也好
它都会回来
所以我们会看到positioning影响
公司引力影响
然后tariff talk就是那个关注的谈判
都把每一股往上推动了不少
就是这个相对来说短期里面
很多的利好把它推上去
但是在这个位置上面
我个人感觉是我心里的uprange
就是我心里感觉的是一个比较偏高的位置
不是特别的安全
原因就是我对于经济基本面的一个判断
就是我感觉现在
我对于经济基本面的判断是连储不太行动
然后美国会slow down
这种情况下面公司的earning是要下降
就是如果说我们假设
假设像高盛的预期的话
今年引力增加3%
那个在这里
就是说今年市场预期大概6%
然后高盛预期3%
当然有mog standing预期会比较高一点
那如果说是5%左右的话
那么是这个earning是大概255块钱
就是S&P大概255块钱
那么你觉得应该给几倍PE呢
就是说那个我们可以说不完全柯州求见
因为一般来说你摔退的话
或软着路的话
你要到15倍到20倍之间的
摔退的话到15倍去
现在因为S&P的成分股可以前有点不一样
这个成分中间太多的科技公司
科技公司的就是我们叫它的earning growth
就是它的引力增长是比较快的
所以一般来说会给比较高的PE
但是即使这样我们看到的这些大公司
它的就是Microsoft, Amazon, Google
他们这些大公司
他们的earning growth也在增速也在下降
这个是毋庸置疑的
这些增速下降是比较就比较不变的
一方面是经济的影响吧
另外一方面其实它的这个
这个包括它投入就是投资比较顺的vidium
它说到azek的影响很大
就有很多的公司的这个Kapax
先投到azek上面去
那vidium它的这个earning growth
就自然而然就不会像今年这么强
所以你会看到今年25年
甚至26年他们的earning growth
都应该是一个往下跑的这个趋势
那么在这个情况下面
你很难再给到这个公司这么高的皮
所以你即使是给50倍
而即使你是给那个22倍
其实也就是到前高
就是22倍已经很高了在美国
一般来说你就算有点泡沫了
那你衰退的话是15倍
所以在现在这个价位上呢
我觉得其实有点积累
就是你再去formal在这个位置上
哪怕中国和美国完全谈妥了
在现在这个位置上进去formal
我都是感觉风险就是
堵住的时候
就是你先压住的风险是大于收益的
那么当然了
这个政策还是根据政策改变的
因为你10%的这个recipable tariff是造成了
其实10%recipable tariff基本上造成了
1%的GDP损失和1%的那个通胀
那这个是影响了很多我们本来
就是去年以来很多
就去年以来我一直是觉得经济没有问题
然后通胀也没有问题
所以它可以给到22倍
可以给到23倍
可以给更高
那个就批养S&P能赶到更高
因为公司盈利会很好
经济增长很好
那关税是一个本质的对市场本质的冲击
那它会不会全部取消呢
我个人这个就要看你对政治怎么判断
我的判断是不太会的
因为你看这三件事情
就昨天跟中国的关税协议其实是这样子
就中国和美国互加百分之四
然后其他都是去头拔脑假的
就是美国原来不是加拿大34
然后还有24是根据90天之后的谈判去加的
那个分泰尼是加了20%
但是分泰尼的20%
其实我觉得也更像一个谈判的筹码
所以这件事情都是都是
我感觉都是浮动的
所以是可以取消的
所以市场感觉非常乐观
但是这个也暴露的就是特朗普的关税政策的一个
一个软弱的态度
因为台湾市好像是加了32吧
台湾市直接接受了特朗普的关税条件
直接被加了32
然后他接受了
然后英国跟他谈谈了以后
英国因为对美国没有那么大的贸易逆差的
是美国对英国没有那么大贸易逆差的
相对英国好像还是Flight
还是英国反正不是特别大
他加了英国
他最新引路的就是QOTA制
就是汽车的QOTA制
汽车的配额制
然后同时的话给英国加了10%
所以你可以回头看中国
中国的迪欧至少在Reciprocal Tariff这一方面
跟英国待遇是一样
是远远好过台湾的
这个是非常可笑的一件事情
那么在这个环境里面的
你说后面这些国家还会不会给他腐软
然后给他那个
给他那个加Reciprocal Tariff
我觉得可能就不太会了
所以现在市场可能pricing
就是他的底线就是给所有人加10%
这件事情就了了
但是即使给所有人加10%
也已经到了我们年初预期的一个
比较偏悲观的一个情况
所以这个情况下面
美国会不会衰退呢
我感觉还是有概率会衰退的
这个是我们以前因为年初的时候
就看过这些数据
我们也分析过就是
当时说Reciprocal可能发生
可能不发生
如果不发生的话
会对经济造成大概0.5的影响
对通胀造成0.4到0.5的影响
那如果发生的话
那大概是增加了个1%
就增加到1%以上
所以现在是增加到1%以上
那么经济在四季度和那个
明年一季度
slowdown就变幻
我觉得还是大概率实践
所以短期里面
当然你是吹的一个情绪
那个市场
就是根据你的情绪好坏
然后就是可以可以很换的反弹
但是你如果是
buy and hold
就是做资产配置的话
我觉得还是看
我觉得最后还是看经济和公司的引力
那么
当然了我多说几个吧
就是Pacific做几个公司吧
就是像Intel啊
像Babao啊
甚至像Abago啊
这些公司呢
我觉得还是估值还是相对来说
比较稳定的
比较比较便宜的非常便宜
特别是像Babao这种非常便宜
因为我这个公司好像是
之前我自己买过
然后跌了非常多
但是呢
那个我说一下大概它的情况吧
因为啊
现在这个Azik的趋势还是比较明显的
就是在那个算力上面
一方一种是用GPU嘛
就是那个Navidian这种
另外一种
像Abago和那个Babao
他们的这个Azik
那在Azik整整整包方案里面
其实只有Abago和Babao
那么像Babao是属于一个弹性非常高的公司
因为你就是这些大公司吧
就是你云厂和那个Azik公司
签约等于你是我的
你是我的总包商
现在总包商他能够披露的细节是非常少
所以他的那个NDA签了很严格
他不能明天出来说
我拿到了比较说
我拿到Trinity 3或者我拿到Trinity 4
我现在Trinity 4的这个进度是怎么样
他没有办法跟市场很好的不同
所以呢
一旦那个市场在down turn的时候
就会有很多
因为而且这种这种仓位里面
Hedge fund position很重
所以一旦down turn的时候呢
Hedge fund就会把他的股票都卖掉
或者是吵一些新闻就做空谈
那个像Abago为什么没有跌那么多
像比较Mao
就是Abago没有那么多
就是他以前的Track Rocker比较好
因为他做时间比较长
他一直拿着Google的TPU
那Google TPU其实也在看各种方式
就是内部的解决方案和外部的解决方案
也在看
那么像那个因为Abago以前的那个Track Rocker
比较坚持
所以他讲的这个Earning预期出来
大家都比较买账
但是像Abago这种
因为他做的比较新
他是他是转型
刚刚去做挨择的这种东西
所以呢
大家对于他后面拿单的能力
其实有质疑的
那最近一些时间出来
比方说说到Microsoft的单
Microsoft的Maya 3
那个可是2027年的事情
那个他今年的盈利
三块钱是很确定的
那明年可能增长70%到80%
我觉得这也是很确定的
包括那个他们讲到
就是True 3和True 4的这些时间
其实这个都是因为Hatchphone Position里面
他经常会炒作一些新闻
然后去买卖
所以像Abago这种
就变成很好的一个操控标的
因为公司很难在这个层面
突破他保密协议的限制
NDA的限制
然后去去跟市场沟通太多的东西
所以我这个是一个例子
包括那个Intel
市场现在一直在猜
他会不会拿到就是Microsoft的订单
网卡订单
那这个订单其实并不是非常大
像18A的订单不是非常大
但是我说一件事情
就说所有的半导体的东西
都是十二个月到十八个月的
所以这个事情早就定下来
他并不是今天成立五上台以后
然后才搞定的事情
这个是这个PAD在台上
其实已经在Test
已经在走线已经在亮灯
所以其实每一个东西
就是我们如果回头
对行业比较了解的话
就是他18A的凉率
其实不错的情况下
那个很多东西
他是相对来说比较确定
像Intel比较缺的一样东西
他是缺市场对他的
就是他缺市场的一个
市场怎么设定
设这个这个这个产线
然后跟市场的沟通比较少
他比较闭门造册
所以他更加需要的是
比方说那个Kalence
或者是Kalence一个团队
或者是那个Navidian一个团队
在上面跟他去去留片
然后跟他跑跑流程
但是那个供应方就是
就是假方
以前不太敢在那个Intel上面跑
跑的话一方面得要花很多钱
我帮你做研发做开发嘛
另外一方面他们也怕得罪台积电
那么怕得罪那个TSM
那么陈立武其实上台在Intel之后
他解决了很大程度上解决了这个问题
因为陈立武等于是
华登的时候是那个TSM的
扣方的了等于是
反来说等于是他这个
他是那个重要的财务投资人
所以不太会
就是他跟那个TSM的关系是非常非常近的
而且他原来是Kalence的CEO嘛
所以他能够找到有外部的团队
去磨合那个Intel
就是现有的18A的这个产线
那么这个我觉得陈立武的能力是比较强的
所以这两个像这种红色的话
就这两个是我个人的一个持倉
所以我就跟大家分享一下
就如果说你们会觉得
哪一些东西的培律
现在如果说要去压住
哪些东西的培律比较好
我是感觉一些AI的公司
和那个Semiconductor一些半导体的公司
现在的估值其实往下的空间
和往上的空间来说
往上的空间会更大
但是如果说你们去压住在
比方说Falence里面
比方说银行投行
比方说Google啊
或者压在那个Goldman
或者是压在那个Morgan Stanley这种公司的股票里
那其实你对于后续
特朗普政策放松多少
就Deregulation放松多少
压住是挺大的
所以它会就整体SNP
我会觉得风险是Leaning on downside
就是整体SNP的话
往下就是往下的风险
你同时压住的概率
就是我们叫预期收益吧
往下的这个风险会比往上的大
但是有一些Sector
就是前一段时间跌了比较多的
半导体和AI
那往上的风险会更大一点
所以这个是个人平衡
但是我还是不太建议很大参谓去做风险
因为整体我的Fundamental的判断是
即使在10%的Receivable Tariff的情况下面
市场是需要
就是市场的Earning的增长
是需要往下调整
也就是说在这个位置上面
它要降到5%以内
就是25年要降到5%以内的
那个现代市场预期大6%
所以而且一季度的数据
一季度的Earning Growth相对来说比较好
你可以看这个蓝的点
这个Tracking现在还是比较好的
那么Tracking比较好
并不是一个特别好的信号
因为市场暗含的这个Earning Growth相对来说
可能到10%吧
因为你现在其实市场
就在当前市场给的定价是21VPE增长10%
就是那个Earning Growth增长10%
然后给了21VPE是这样一个状态
所以相对来说
跟我的基本面的判断来说
我觉得有点风险了
然后那个其他的话
我觉得上一位美人的
我另外想讲的一件事情
可能想一下那个Chump Premium
和讲一下那个利率吧
利率市场就是最近一段时间
还在往上
Rece还在往上跑
然后国债在走弱
那么利率这个市场
其实有几方面的
我对于利率的基本的判断
是可能会小幅的Steepening
但是长端会维持稳定
在大概4.25到4.5左右的水平
现在在4.5基本上
我觉得往上好很多的空间
也不是很大
那么其实几方面吧
就是说利率这东西在短期里面
有很多的因素
可以短期的影响到它
就比方说短期里面
Bump Market会和Risk Assert很相关
因为Risk Assert
Chump Premium会影响到Bump Market
你这个收益比方说
相对于股票大家乐观了
那你这个收益就吸引你就不是那么大了
第二就是美元投资人
因为美元投资人
就是比方说钱会不会流出美国
然后Physical Expansion
就是国家的财政的支出
那么这些都是短期里面的影响
但是我觉得更加Fundamental的一个影响
就是两个
第一个是发债
你今年到底会发多少债
那个因为在美国国令的需求还是为主
就是需求基本上你从Longerton来看
比方说我们看到年纪的利率的话
Longerton来看的话
发债的需求还是比较稳定
这个比去年要少
第二个是Growth增长
那么现在利率上升有很大程度上的
大家对后面的Growth利率就是对于增长
美国增长更加乐观了一点
那么10年期的利率上涨跟增长乐观了一点
但是我基本上感觉
就是在今年三级度四级度
到明年一级度的时候增长会往下方化
所以增长一旦放缓
对于利率
Premium一定是有往下的这个力量
所以综合这些东西来看
就是你发债量也没有特别大几年对吧
所以10年期利率
我觉得就是在4.2 4.3到4.5左右的水平
到看到年底
大概就在这个水平里面
所以现在有很多说
比方说忘了前两天有人说要做空国债
我觉得做空国债也不胜大
现在这个里面已经没有很大意了
那么第三我反馈一下
对于那个贪王普可能会采取的退税的
生存的一个对市场的影响
因为有很多川粉
他们的概念是说
我虽然收税
我现在那个Cherif可能会收200到300亿
200到300个别人
那个美元的这个税
所以你说到年底的时候
他可能会采取退税
那最近一个就是House里面的House and Weight and Means里面
出来这个Tax Plan
Weight and Means叫什么
叫做预算委员会好像
就是那个国会的预算委员会
他出来的Tax Plan是说
我做了5个Trillion Cost
那这个5个Trillion Cost
其实现在已经高于议会的授权了
意味着6月30号的时候
又要去搞一下这个债务上限这些事情
那么最后即使这个Tax Plan被完全落
就是被完全通过
然后你的减税就是特朗普讲的
他要做那些减税
包括你比方说他Tips免税
或者是那个他一系列的公司要退税免税这些东西
他如果是真的是完全通过这些免税计划
他的就是Tax Card的钱给到注入到实体中间
是需要到11月份
所有的这个Monitor Policy
包括收税这些东西
他都是有一个我们叫做有个发酵周期的
就是你的政策下去
并不是马上立马对市场造成影响
马上立马影响的是股市
就是你现在这个是情绪影响
包括前一段时间下跌和这一段时间上涨
就是完全是政治情绪的操纵
但是你对经济实体的影响是需要6个月
那我们现在在4月份加了税
我是觉得半年左右
就是经济实体会受到一些影响
先行指标现在就可以开始影响
但是后面的影响可能要到34
第3基督以后第4基督才会有影响
那么你的退税政策是11月出来
他的影响也是需要时间的
你要到明年年中或者是明年1基督末
所以在我们叫做为什么我用这个图呢
就是林某就是我们现在在一个迷惘期
连处也出一个迷惘期
政策也出一个迷惘期
就是你政策的影响就负面的影响还没完全显现
你证明的政策还没有下去
你既是给的话也没有下去
我时间写错了这5月份的税
那上次讲的是
对你政策正面的政策还没有还没有显现出来
然后你负面政策也没有
你负面政策已经还没有完全显现出来
正面政策还没下去
所以现在就是一个清黄不接的时候
那么为什么为什么那个FAT不会采取行动
因为FAT必须要你的政策确定
他才能够确定
他最怕的就是你我这边去放了钱
然后你又在那里比方说搞tariff
然后把通脏搞上去
那变成我的过了吗
所以你现在所有的政策全是紧急状态政策
就IEPA出的政策
IEPA是那个相当于是那个紧急状态出来的政策
没有一个政策是确定过了议会的
所以JPAL是不会对于没有过议会的政策作出反馈
他一定要等到哈data不管是通脏的data出来
或者是通过shotted的data出来
他才会行动
对于他来说最好的新闻
就是你的政策都没过议会
你今天可以你可以18遍
你们随时可以变化
那么我就不变
以不变应万变
这个是连续的政策
所以我觉得今年可能的一个比较好的投资的方案
也是学连续就是你以不变应万变
有你有的仓问也不要动
就你就放着看了
然后你也不要随便去随的政策
除非你有很明确的政策的判断
就是你对白宫的政策有很明确的判断
不然的话我觉得是你跟着这个
比方说你周末你怎么知道他谈好了谈崩了
对吧
然后其实我甚至不太有信心
90天之后
中国和美国到底是不是一定谈好
我觉得很有可能又会变一次
这个就不谈好讲
但这个就是完全政策的判断
所以这个是连续的一政策
所以我对白宫特朗普这个人的政策
我没有一个明确的判断
我不清楚他到底会怎么搞
我们只能安局现在的情况
就现在放在桌面上的情况
那么我觉得就是我刚才的这个这个一个认知
如果他又把那个
就是把那个recipe code全部给取消了
那就是变成另外一个story
但是我对美连续的态度
我会有更强的信心
就是有非常强的信心
现在JPOP就是这个态度
就是他不要去指望他大规模的降息
或者他会和财政部长谈好
大家一起联手干什么事情
就是绝对没有可能
就是他绝对不会干这个事情
他现在就是一不变
一万变看硬数据
那么在硬数据面前
我们就在走向硬数据下降的过程中间
这个过程中间有点清黄不浅
所以我觉得这个中间是会有一些风险的
那么接下去我们几个星期可能
这个数据这个可以做一个参考吧
这是高升对于那个tariff的一个impact的一个影响
但是他没有根据那个调整
没有根据对中国政策的调整
所以你可以认为他整体会往上
大概0.4左右吧
0.4 GDP会往上0.4左右的影响
所以会往上
你可以把这条线往上放0.4左右
大概是因为把中国的关税给最好
就真的变10%就这个取消了
那么就往上放0.4
所以仍然不是一个特别乐观的情况
我们继续观察他的这个政策变化
那个对于对于白宫的政策
我觉得很难做判断
但是对于连处的政策
就是刚才我的我的一个基本看法
我们今年还是要根据这个市场的情况
做不停的做切切
这个这个人没有办法
好吧那个看一下大家有些什么样的问题
我这边先那个我会走我这边回答一下